(speaks Spanish)
(Latin guitar music)
(upbeat Latin music)
- [Voiceover] If you're on the
beach, this is what you want.
You don't any of that Bud Light shit.
- Um, it doesn't really
taste like anything,
which I sort of enjoy.
- Oh! That's okay.
- It tastes like a penny.
- The entire flavor lasts
for about 15 seconds
on your tongue.
- [Voiceover] "Sol", which in Spanish...
- [Both] Means "sun".
- This seems like knockoff Corona.
I'm on board.
- There's like a pee vibe
I'm getting on this one.
Pee pee?
- It's cardboard-y.
- Whoa!
This is like a little cider-y.
- Bud Light is a little
aggressive compared to this.
- [Voiceover] Indio.
- To be honest, to me, this
does not taste good at all.
- This is like a Mexican Guinness.
- Okay, that's got more kick.
- This tastes sort of the same.
- They're way different.
- I like that one.
- Yeah, it's caramel-y.
- Oh, Modelo!
- (chanting) Modelo, Modelo!
- This is like the chode of beer bottles.
It's short and stout.
- Unfortunately you can't be
classy when you open this beer.
Talk about making you angry
when you're supposed to be
enjoying your barbecue.
- I'm not saying
cigarettes are cool, kids,
'cause they're not, but I'm
just saying, the badassery
that comes with it is here in a Modelo.
- Not for me.
Tastes like weed.
- Fucking good.
It's really fucking good.
- [Voiceover] I was gonna
use the bottle opener,
but Tecate's...
- I like see it, and I trust it.
It has this like trustworthy...
- [Voiceover] You trust it, it's like a...
- I trust the red.
- That's fine.
- These are the worst.
- That is smooth.
That's the smoothest one we've had so far.
- It's okay.
- Tastes like pee.
- You were hyping it up so much!
- [Voiceover] I like this.
- This one's more bitter than the others.
- Victoria.
(laughs)
- This tastes like nothing to me.
- That's a nice beer.
- That's a good beer!
- I like this beer.
(mimics choir singing)
- I like it.
(mimics trumpet)
- They're all good.
This one's best.
- It's a tie between Corona and Modelo.
- Modelo.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, it was
the best one, for sure.
- If I'm like already really drunk,
I'm gonna go for Sol.
But this one tastes like
cider, so I'm a big fan.
- I like Modelo 'cause it
actually tastes like beer.
- I like Miss La Victoria.
- I like Victoria; I like the name of it.
- I know why Corona's the
most popular Mexican beer.
It really does taste the best.
- This is the best one.
- Indio's my favorite.
- Corona's my favorite.
- Who's Modelo is that?
Oh, it's mine.
Oh no it's not, it's yours.
- Get in here.
- Why are these bottles...
- We're cheersing!
(laughs)
- Okay cheers, we gotta cheers.
- Cheers!
(bottles clank)
- Justin!
(screams and laughs)